The midpoint is located right here. The coordinates of that point are 100 and
350. When I figured this out the first time, I basically eyeballed where I
thought halfway along the line was, and then figure out the coordinates of that
point. But is there a way that we can use the coordinates of the two points on
the line that we already know to find the coordinates of the point halfway
between them? In fact, there is. We know that home is located at 0,0, the
origin, and the Udacity is located at 200 700,. Going halfway between these
points, means going both halfway in the x-direction and halfway in the
y-direction. So, let's look at those coordinates individually. For the
x-coordinate, we start at 0 and we want to go halfway to 200, half of the
distance between 0 and 200 is 100. So, you just go over that much. That
automatically gives us our x-coordinate. The y-coordinate works in pretty much
the same way. Our initial y-coordinate of home is 0, we want to go up 700, to
where Udacity located vertically. This distance is 700 miles, so half of 700 is
350.